so when i look around this audience
especially because i've been in the
community it's a little harder than it
was in web20 when everyone actually used
their face as their avatar and now we we
have very different things but i have a
good sense of a lot of entrepreneurship
uh a lot of creative energy in the room
from from a big brand perspective todd
when you first
heard about
nfts
you know as as a dude and i think you're
very on the pulse both of you are hence
why i wanted you here uh but how did it
first land did you have the cynical
point of view of like i don't get it
like why would somebody own it did it
immediately hit
where did you go the first time you kind
of understood
this thing is happening
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
yeah i think um i think like all of you
here you know you see the potential for
it you see you know hey this will be the
dmv years from now the ticket but all
the different applications of the
technology
um but then you also look at it against
the market very consumer first and i
look at the experience right now that
it's so early days the consumer
experience is actually pretty funny
right you've got to register for digital
wallet you've got to give all this
personal information you've got gas fees
you've got you got all this conversion
all these steps as this
begins to tip that will hopefully all
converge and become much more useful
deeper into it and really understand
kind of the intricacies and why people
are doing it we're starting to really
you know delve into the space so will i
be able to in the future buy a token
that allows me to perform in the pepsi
halftime super bowl show
[Applause]
i can't sing for [ __ ]
then
when you think of the idea of brands and
how people connect to different brands
and i think as you were saying the
different affinities people had
sports music entertainment you know the
utility that it gets in your everyday
life um there's a ton of possibilities
as we look at kind of how we would want
to connect with consumers in this space
and so i think we're trying to be really
you know think about it the right way
and not just rush in and just say hey
we did one but really strategically
figure out what's kind of the long play
you know how do we want to get into
space authentically how do we want to
really just one two three and kind of
step in because i think to your point
while there forces money to be made and
there's a whole transactional piece you
know as far as brand building as well
that's that's another big benefit to us
as well beyond kind of the financial you
know piece as well when you look at the
scale that's actually even more
beneficial to us
given that both of you were in the
marketing game i think but correct me if
i'm wrong but i'm pretty sure about this
when social web 2 happened 2006 seven
five eight
you have more confidence
that you can enter the space more
authentically because you learned
through the trials and tribulations of
that hard transition from web one to web
two traditional media to social
do you feel
do you feel the companies of your size
have more confidence of hey this is what
happened and we misplayed at social if
we look back at six and seven do you
feel that gives you a leg up to play
three better than two you know i think
just to answer your question too the um
i look at the parallels from i remember
when the big first you know web 2.0
happened and all this and just there
were a lot of um executives and people
in the company are like they're saying
something bad about us on facebook
the fact that all these things are
coming so quickly i think there's an
acknowledgment from a lot of the big
companies like ours did
[ __ ] we don't know but we know this is
going to be a thing so let's honk her
down let's get our legal team our
financing
you know like all of that stuff that
just big companies have to wrestle with
but i think there's a lot more
willingness uh to kind of dive in then
i'd say some of the early days stuff
given that it's pepsi and budweiser
super bowl world cup halftime show
how is this
framework gonna affect the way you look
at sponsorships and maybe even more
importantly
how you look at the
humans that you do brand deals with
i think even though i understand the
deal structure piece of it as well
right now as you look at friends we're
making a tv commercial if we're signing
someone it's a transactional one-way i'm
going to pay person x they're going to
provide my service we're going to
both hopefully benefit in that regard if
this is a game changer to a partnership
where it's like hey
we can both come out of this you know
both building equity making money doing
you know positive things for consumers
all in the same way we've built it
correctly yes i do think there's gonna
be a view where
and things like that what about for a
lot of people in this audience
who are
smaller artists or entrepreneurs
do you feel that
do you feel like this is a time where
as brands try to enter and look for
authenticity or try to find their way
that for people here that may dream to
do business with brands of this size
because they have the knowledge and the
context for the space is this an
opportune time for for them to dream and
kind of try to reach out and do things
or is because it's new there's a little
bit more fear with big brand and a
smaller entrepreneur artist might be a
liability is it a pro or is it a con
yeah i'll just say um i completely agree
the only thing i would add
as you think about a big brand sitting
in this space it's also difficult
because there's so many
new entrants coming in every day to know
10 years from now who's left saying
right
and you could get you saw him with ar
but that was the new hot [ __ ] everyone
was doing like hey it's like someone can
do it better than others some might not
and
so that that's the thing that's i think
because it's so early it's a little
difficult but i do believe to your point
seeing all the energy and creativity
coming from all the different projects
all the different careers is
what about on a personal level like
where are you like have you
did you need to like figure it out did
you like give away your seed phrase to
somebody by accident like on a personal
level like where are you on your on your
journeys
right now
just kind of getting my feet wet into
space
and
just to um the wallet and get in there
and get in there and figure out what the
[ __ ] is there somewhere i got hurt you
know
look alike of some
[ __ ] that i thought
as you get in there you go through it
but it's actually for me that's the most
valuable you know putting myself in
consumer shoes and trying to really
empathize with what has really happened
to space
and uh it's been it's been awesome
continue to get into it
i think your take there is really right
it's a lot easier for us to take photos
to tell the world what we want them to
know
if we know what you're buying it's a
dramatically real indicator to what
you're about and i actually think
that's why we had that convo and i think
you're right what um what what do you
what do you feel when you see
this
energy like what what's as you've been
taking in
kind of just being here just even
watching like for me
actually i'll jump in where i'm going
with that question as i sit here and i'm
doing this interview
this is exactly what i felt like in 2006
and seven at south by southwest about
webb because it was almost like there
was a lot of curiosity and optimism
in the room
because i know you guys focus on the
consumer and i think the point you made
that i think a lot of people should hear
is when you're running when you have the
responsibility that you two have in
running brands of this size you do have
to care about scale
when you see the kernel of the future
and all these pretty faces
what what comes to mind as
oh [ __ ] we we need i need to take this
back home we really need to think about
this that or the other thing anything
stand out
i'd say what i mean excitement hope you
know uh just the energy you know
walking around the floor singing hearing
conversations meeting folks i mean the
energy is unlike anything else right and
the fact that it is a
you know
people who are in you know are all right
inspiring to see as a big company
knowing like this is a space where we're
going to continue to start to play and
just see for the future
i think in in wrapping up the thing that
really stands out for me in the
difference of web 2 and web 3 with
brands
is in web 2
everyone in the audience was building on
top of communication not consumerization
right so it was about how we
communicated so when brands came in
there was a lot of pushback because it
was corporate it was business
in this space
unless you're a hypocrite i think we can
all agree
which i think is a vulnerability for our
space right now way too much energy is
about the financial part if you look
very carefully
people are 80 percent of the [ __ ] in
this space right now are day trading
digital assets
and so
[Applause]
what's interesting there's nothing wrong
with that i love a good garage sale but
what it does is actually gives brands
subconscious more room to do things
because most people realize they're
having a lot of business dna and what
they're doing as well and if brands play
it right
they can benefit from that a lot more
than what happened in o6 when it was a
completely different conversation and i
think that lends itself to a lot of
opportunity for youtube but very
honestly i think that lends itself to a
huge opportunity to all of you and and
even though
todd and richard kind of painted a very
true picture to you which i appreciated
of like how big of a leap that has to be
for you to jv with a brand of this size
much like i've told you in the content
about getting to influencers on dm i
still believe that this is so hot
and there's so much momentum that
there's somebody who literally launched
a project three weeks ago that can make
a jv with a national bubblegum brand or
a cereal brand and i and i hope this
gave you some insight to how they're
thinking which is why i wanted to do
this panel to just give a little context
and i hope everybody here has a
tremendous time this week and i hope
everybody follows my twitter tonight
because i'm throwing a secret wine party
which i haven't done in a decade
i've got
i've got a [ __ ] load of wine
i have no idea where i'm doing it
and as soon as i find a spot i'm
tweeting it out so i hope i see every
one of you [ __ ] people tonight thank
you so much
thank you
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon